[Music]
thank you
an Alien Spider just bit my fingers an
alien Cliff you can just say spider yes
but the spider's still alien from
Morty's point of view it'd be pretty
confusing if Morty found an earth spider
on this mountain so specifying its alien
origin feels pretty warranted and
everyone knows the pedantry is more fun
when it's safe for the really important
stuff like critiquing software cartoons
on the internet also this episode opens
with a pretty clear Star Trek V the one
with God reference which has led us to
using this side-by-side comparison to
prove it which has led to all of us
watching more Star Trek 5 the one with
God than we ever need to which has
rather fittingly led to sin
suits will I be sending this scene
because it uses the phrase anti-boobie
even though I know for a fact it's
talking about booby traps and not actual
boobies yeah yeah look we all like
saying booby but someone has to nip
these inaccuracies in the bud also great
idea but what if this place contained
traps that didn't rely on projectiles
with these suits have been useful
against disappearing Bridges quicksand
or those irritating statues where one
always speaks the truth and the other
one always lies more like trying to hard
con or more like trying too hard to come
up with an insult for the heist Khan
that is trying too hard Khan or
something Khan yes sir fans Morty which
we are not guests don't have to be fans
in fact there are plenty of people out
there who attend things or watch movies
they know they'll hate so they can give
themselves something to complain about
which honestly fits Rick to a [ __ ]
tea I'm not one to judge based on
physical appearance but the fact that
this individual's eye is not fully
connected to their body is giving me all
of the heebie-jeebies and I would like
it to stop please thanks for doing this
guys what's the job that was it bye I
would say I feel bad for glar Angie
flint and Dracula but they chose to show
up at the location without even knowing
what the job was so that's kind of on
them it's showtime Morty and I don't
mean a bad impression of HBO
Yellowjackets Twin Peaks the return turn
in the first six seasons of Dexter would
like to have a word with you lab coat
rip off doctors
we developed a sentient lab coat then I
guess he's kind of ripping off doctor
strange but also Rick developed a
sentient lab coat why isn't he using
that more often your booze mean nothing
I've seen
the reason I'm able to read YouTube
comments somehow makes its way into the
script
by far the worst one I'm just gonna go
ahead and send myself for liking Ocean's
12. I have no good excuses I just love
watching people enjoy European Vacation
gonna go ahead and give myself a sin for
liking National Lampoon's European
Vacation as well oink oink my good man
these eight or just three of Sanchez's
five that's not how math Works Morty
well no Heist is complete without a
double cross okay maybe nightly
predicted Rick would take the bait at
the tomb which would result in the
highest off but how could he even known
Rick's team would be so willing to
portray Rick especially when Rick has a
reputation for murder
What the hi what the sh what are you
doing here I'm you but from several
minutes in the future look this episode
gets Mighty and confusing If You Don't
Know How It Ends so I'm here to set you
straight when needed makes sense but
what's with the weirdly deep announcery
voice don't worry that'll make sense
later the important thing is that these
three were specially selected by Rick
because he knew they'd betray him so I
guess just do the thing where we sit in
the show for the time we wasted writing
a sin that it later disproves see ya
okay
um yeah what he slash I said and I had
the perfect job heisting the Crystal
Skull he got the skull already looks
like Rick and Morty left their crew and
went straight to see nightly on stage so
how did nightly have enough time to
recruit Rick's heisters set the heist in
motion and
again already sorry buddy we're about to
see there's a huge time gap between Rick
and Morty leaving the crew and then them
turning up a nightly show and that's
when all the heisting happens we're
better off sitting that there's no way
nightly could have known Rick was going
to dick around for a few hours before
coming to see him which is the only way
Knightley had enough time to pull off
the heist okay thank you but wouldn't it
be better to just lay all this out now
and save some time
looks like you're available for a job
Rick and Morty literally just laughed
could nightly not have waited until they
were leased out of earshot okay let's
take a second to talk through this Heist
glar steals some keys and hands them off
the key catcher who hands them off the
double microwave who well microwaves
them as a distraction to presumably
clear out security they couldn't have
microwaved anything metal why did they
have to go through the effort of
stealing the specific set of keys
[Music]
did the [ __ ] shapeshifter just
shape-shift in front of the damn camera
I don't care if the crew is in charge of
the surveillance room now that's still
recorded footage of their actual
identity why even risk it knew that
shirt off screen we're smart we'll
figure it out also they turn into the
security guard give the thumbs up and
the next thing that happens is that
monitor Lord switches off the lasers
allowing Angie to steal the skull why
the [ __ ] does the crew need a security
guard at this point
all right I'm trying to figure out how
miles didn't know by the weight of the
attache that there wasn't a crystal
skull in it I'm not saying he should
have known it was a recent Deuce Rick
dropped but the stench alone should have
given something away God damn it Morty
what did I tell you you gave him a time
limit that he needed to pay attention to
but this is also the kid that said half
of nightly's eight or just three of
Sanchez's five so I'm pretty sure you
should have been the one checking the
clock Rick write an algorithm based on
two heist movies I slept through and
used it to automate a joyless process
you call Art Rick clearly has an issue
with the heist genre being overly
formulaic and predictable but sometimes
it's that very predictability that
brings people to comfort and joy they
need from their movie watching
experience we don't all have to like the
same stuff and we don't all have to
agree except for Army of the Dead [ __ ]
that movie somehow no one in this long
line catches on to what's happening
until all of them get hypnotized look
Morty I did not know that that was gonna
happen that's not on me that's not how
homicide law works
holy
told you Morty
he's still got it oh come on the entire
universe is in danger and yet Rick took
the time to recruit all of these
students to set up this attack just to
prove that Professor poopy butthole has
damn it what now hey I'm with you on
this one but they're gonna make the same
point in the post-credits scene and
steal our thunder so I think we'd better
send them for leaning on callbacks to
characters no one likes but I like Mr
poofy butthole no you don't
are you ventriloquiver
in this episode alone we've seen Rick
block a hammer with a sudden robot arm
but a [ __ ] Arrow hits the mark how
I'm sure it's not the show sacrificing
its Integrity just to show us a unique
superpower Rick Sanchez I presume damn
it guys Elon Tusk listen we need your
help Rick Morty why me Elon Musk
oh look what could possibly be wrong
here this thing is quite good hello
there steady on no objections here at
all I just wanted to come back and send
this one again oh cool
at this point heistatron has become
large enough to Heist entire planets but
is it even heisting anymore everyone on
this planet knows that they're being
heisted are we supposed to believe that
there's no way to scale up a heist to a
planetary level that doesn't just
involve making all the gadgets bigger at
this point it isn't heisting it's just
breaking and entering with a sprinkling
of genocide instead of two heist movies
I slept through Rando tron's algorithm
is derived from the plots of three David
Lynch movies I pretended to like to make
my friends shut up for me the crucial
question here is which three David Lynch
movies I think it's only fair that we're
told where on the spectrum between Dune
and blue velvet this is going to be so
we know the best way to pretend we've
seen either one if our Collective
behavior is just random enough we should
be able to walk through heistatrons
lazily contrive [ __ ] like it's not
even there but even choosing to be
random is a plan if the end goal is to
out Heist heistotron relying on
Randomness will either be so random that
you never get to the desired outcome or
not be random enough to not be predicted
by heistotron I don't like these little
Jabs you get in Elon signed literally
all of Twitter surprisingly my issue
here isn't the consumption of diapers
but the fact that this box specifies
fresh suggests there is a not-fresh
diaper alternative on sale the most
unbelievable part of this episode is
that Morty's room would be this clean
I've got something to tell you let me
guess when you invented me and randotron
you've swapped our brains if he knew
heistatron was going to go Rogue why
does it even need randotron why couldn't
he would just program to Fail-Safe into
Heist
here we go again buddy believe me I am
with you but the next five minutes are
going to get super [ __ ] weird and I'm
still not certain how many switchers
actually make sense and honestly I'm not
sure the show does either let's send it
for Rick labeling these brains and then
immediately switching the labels just
for the purposes of the flashback that
heistertron can't see to compensate for
a Switcheroo Rick couldn't possibly have
predicted
what well if the brain inside of you is
actually heistatrons it matters because
it explodes when it hits six levels of
contrivance I mean could he not have
made it four and saved us all some time
in migraines well Rick randotron I'm
afraid not but if Rick built both
machines how the [ __ ] did he manage to
switch out its own motherboard and why
did it need to bother with this earlier
Switcheroo also this is heistotron that
means this was randotron which means it
shouldn't have blown up after that sixth
contrivance because I programmed you to
believe that I programmed you to believe
that I programmed you to believe that
robot kids what's happening for
me
it's fair to say that nothing within
this rambling incoherence could be
considered learning in fact I would
argue that we're all dumber for having
experienced it Ricky mortiston should be
awarded no points and may God have mercy
on our souls it appears the only perfect
Heist is one that was never written
goodbye Rick and Morty writers create a
paradox they have no idea how to solve
so they blow it up deny its existence or
banish it to an alternate reality cliche
well you know that screenplay that I've
been writing Netflix is pretty
interesting morning I'm so excited for
you wait is Rick being sincere right now
about a Netflix deal what is
okay last one I promise we're about to
find out that Rick with his Adventure in
Emotion just to disillusion Morty and
make him sour to his own high script
however I think we're safe to send him
for the many many millions of people
that had to die just so that Rick could
crush his grandson's passion for a
project oof that's messed up even for
Rick right see you at the sin removal
wait the what now well let's hear about
this Heist movie okay so it's kind of
all built around this big crew with like
a cool double cross and then this big
awesome twist expecting us to believe
that Netflix didn't green light this at
okay and then cancel it by awesome twist
if Morty ever gives up on a single dream
it is better be because of his own
dissolutionment somehow Rick and Morty
manages to pull off sitting everything
Trophy and cliche about heist movies
while also inceptioning itself into an
excellent homage of an example of how to
do the genre in a unique and satisfying
way oh and on that sin removal I guess
it's time to head back and make sure
past me doesn't make a bigger ass of
myself than usual I still don't
understand the deep voice thing but
better safe than paradoxed am I right I
got a date with density
[Music]
you think this is funny well Terry it
sure is [ __ ] ain't sad
why ten thousand years will give you
such a trick in the neck you forgot the
power gloves
today still wanted by the government
they survive as Soldiers of Fortune if
you have a problem if no one else can
help and if you can find them maybe you
can hire The A-Team respect the
heistatron State your prime directive
the draymonds are not a subject for
philosophical debates they are a people
your life as it has been is over from
this time forward you will service us
well let's hear about this Heist movie
this is your basic mortgage all right
The Originals were simple they were just
thousands of AAA mortgages bundled
together guaranteed by the US government